as well and it comes from the ice
summer of change underweight with the
vegas golden knights this morning the
team fired head coach pete deboer after
missing the playoffs for the first time
in franchise history sports director
chris matthews is live with the details
of
chris deboer's largely successful run
here and now the search for a new coach
chris
well thank you very much john yeah when
you think about this peter deboer at 9
o'clock this morning they made the
announcement that they're going to go in
a different direction there are many
reasons perhaps for his firing you can
point to the 513 missed man hours of of
games due to injuries this season
perhaps even the robin leonard debacle
where is he in is he out is he injured
why is he on the bench if he's injured
maintenance stays so there's that
there's also but if you look over my
shoulder there are three banners here
hanging at city national uh arena here
of course in 2019 20 they last in the
conference finals to dallas in five
games in 2021 as you recall just that
was a short time ago they lost in the
stanley cup semis to montreal in six
games and perhaps the main reason why
the board was let go there will be no
banner hanging up there this year
because for the first time in franchise
history they did miss the postseason no
playoffs they finished fourth in the
pacific division so peter deboer is out
overall with the vegas gold knights 98
wins 50 losses 12 losses in overtime so
just over 500 564 a winning percentage
here with the vegas gold knights which
is actually better than his overall
percentage when he coached uh new jersey
the florida panthers and of course a lot
of us remember when he was coaching the
san jose sharks but peter deboer out as
head coach might also mention what's
next perhaps berry trots barry trots in
the vegas golden knights uh president of
hockey operations george mcphee they go
way back they had a history clear back
with the hershey bears so they've known
each other rick talking another name
there'll be other names bannered around
those two are most prominent there's
some coaches right now that are still
coaching that the vegas golden knights
were very interested in so boy i'll tell
you what in this city we have a graphic
it is literally win or go home as you
can see gerard gallant was fired of
course peter deboer was fired you look
at the raiders they've also lost a
couple of coaches so this is one of
those cities they just go down through
the list you can see the aces they have
a new head coach becky hammond is now
here lambie is out the fc lights five
different coaches the men and women's
basketball coaches over at you know
they've made a change there and of
course in unlv football so lots of
changes one o'clock kelly mccrimmon the
general manager of the vegas gold
knights will address the media and we'll
ask him about this situation that
happened this morning reporting live
from city national i'm chris matthews 8
sports now